انطلق مؤتمر استانا لتسويه السوريه بجولته
العشرين وهذه المره التركيز على تطبيع
العلاقات السوريه التركيه وهو الاول من
نوعه على مستوى نواب وزراء خارجيات سوريا
وروسيا وايران وتركيا وبحضور امم يتراسها
المبعوث دير بادرسون لمناقشه خريطه طريق
وضعتها روسيا بهدف طبعا ردم هل هو
والخلافات بين كل من تركيا وسوريا الجوله
العشرين من مباحثات استانا ستستمر ليومين
بحضور مراقبين من الامم المتحده ومن لبنان
والعراق والاردن وستبحث بطبيعه الحال
التغيرات في الوضع الاقليمي بشان سوريا
والوضع على الارض والجهود المبذوله نحو
التسويه شامله في سوريا ومكافحه الارهاب
سوريا هنا مشاهدينا شددت على انسحاب تركيا
من سوريا باعتبار المدخل الوحيد لاي علاقه
عادله بين البلدين وان مكافحه الارهاب لا
تتم
وان ضمان امن الحدود مسؤوليه طبعا سوريا
وتركيا مشتركه في ظل هذا الاصرار السوري
على الانسحاب والامتناع التركيه عن ذلك
تحدثت مصادر سوريه عن احتمال قبول دمشق
باتفاقا ينص على انسحاب تركي تدريجي لكن
بضمانات روسيه اما ايران وبعد عده لقاءات
مع الوفد السوري والتركي رفضت اي عمل يمس
بسوريا والذي لن يؤدي الا الى تصعيد
الاوضاع في المنطقه ولاجل ذلك فعلى الوفود
المشاركه في استانا ان تعمل على مساله
تطبيع العلاقات بين دمشق من جهه وانقره من
جهه اخرى وفقت طبعا لاحترام وللاحترام
المتبادل وسلامه اراضي سوريا ووحدتها
وسيادتها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات